à des graphiques à l'échelle nanométrique
entièrement créés par des micro-organismes issus du génie génétique
et qui brillent dans le noir.
Nous avons ré-imaginé le moucharabié,
un archétype de l'ancienne architecture arabe,
et créé un écran où chaque ouverture est taillée de manière unique
pour façonner la forme de la lumière et la chaleur qui passent à travers.
Dans notre prochain projet,
nous explorons la possibilité de créer une cape et une jupe --
c'était pour un défilé parisien avec Iris van Herpen --
comme une deuxième peau, en un seul morceau,
avec des contours rigides et une taille flexible.
Avec Statasys, un imprimeur 3D et un collaborateur de longue durée,
nous avons imprimé en 3D cette cape et cette jupe
sans coutures entre les cellules,
et je vais vous montrer d'autres objets similaires.
Ce casque combine des matières rigides et molles
avec une précision de 20 microns.
Cela correspond à un cheveu humain.
C'est aussi la résolution d'un tomodensitomètre.
Que les designers aient accès
à des outils analytiques et synthétiques de si grande précision
nous permet de créer des produits
adaptés non seulement à la forme de notre corps,
mais aussi à la composition physiologique de nos tissus.
Ensuite, nous avons créé une chaise acoustique,
une chaise qui serait à la fois structurelle, confortable
et qui absorberait également le son.
Le professeur Carter, mon collaborateur, et moi
avons cherché l'inspiration dans la nature,
et en créant ce motif surfacique irrégulier,
cela absorbe le son.
Nous avons imprimé cette surface à partie de 44 propriétés différentes,
ayant différentes rigidités, opacités et couleurs,
correspondant à des points de pression du corps humain.
Sa surface, comme dans la nature, a une fonctionnalité qui varie
non pas en ajoutant un autre matériau ou un autre assemblage,
mais en faisant continuellement et délicatement varier
les propriétés de la matière.
Mais la nature est-elle idéale ?
N'y a-t-il pas de pièces détachées dans la nature ?
Je n'ai pas été élevée dans une famille juive pratiquante,
mais quand j'étais petite,
ma grand-mère me racontait des histoires de la bible hébraïque,
et l'une d'entre elles m'est restée et a défini ce à quoi je tiens vraiment.
Comme elle raconte :
« Le troisième jour de la Création, Dieu ordonne à la Terre
de faire pousser un arbre à fruits. »
Pour cet arbre à fruits, il n'y avait pas de différence
entre le tronc, les branches, les feuilles et les fruits.
L'arbre entier était un fruit.
Au lieu de cela, la terre a fait pousser un arbre
qui a une écorce, des tiges et des fleurs.
La terre a créé un monde fait de pièces détachées.
Je me demande souvent :
« Que serait le design si les objets étaient en un seul morceau ?
Retournerions-nous à un stade meilleur de la création ? »
Nous avons cherché ce matériau biblique,
le genre de matériau de l'arbre à fruits, et nous l'avons trouvé.
Le second bio-polymère le plus abondant sur la planète s'appelle la chitine,
et quelques 100 millions de tonnes en sont produites chaque année
par des organismes tels que les crevettes, les crabes, les scorpions, les papillons.
Nous pensions que si nous pouvions adapter ses propriétés,
nous pourrions générer des structures qui sont multifonctionnelles
et en un seul morceau.
C'est ce que nous avons fait.
Nous avons appelé Legal Seafood --
(Rires)
nous avons commandé des carapaces de crevettes,
nous les avons écrasées et avons produit une pâte de chitosan.
En faisant varier les concentrations chimiques,
nous avons réussi à obtenir une grande variété de propriétés --
d'un matériau sombre, rigide et opaque
à un clair, mou et transparent.
Afin d'imprimer les structures à grande échelle,
nous avons construit un système d'extrusion robotisé à orifices multiples.
Le robot faisait varier en permanence les propriétés de la matière
et créait ces structures de 3 mètres de long faite d'une seule matière,
100% recyclables.
Quand les morceaux sont prêts, on les met à sécher
et ils prennent forme naturellement au contact de l'air.
Pourquoi nous entêtons-nous à fabriquer des objets en plastique ?
Les bulles d'air qui étaient un sous-produit du processus d'impression
contenaient des micro-organismes photosynthétiques
qui sont apparus sur Terre il y a 3,5 milliards d'années,
comme nous l'avons appris hier.
Avec nos collaborateurs à Harvard et au MIT,
nous avons intégré des bactéries issues du génie génétique
afin de capturer rapidement le carbone dans l'atmosphère
et de le transformer en sucre.
Pour la première fois,
nous avons été capables de générer des structures
ayant une transition parfaite
d'un morceau à un maillage,
et à une échelle encore plus grande, à une fenêtre.
Un arbre à fruits.
En travaillant avec un vieux matériau,
l'une des premières formes de vie sur la planète,
beaucoup d'eau et un peu de biologie synthétique,
nous avons pu transformer une structure faite de carapaces de crevettes
en une architecture qui se comporte comme un arbre.
Et voici le meilleur :
des objets conçus pour se bio-dégrader,
mettez-les dans la mer et ils nourriront la vie marine ;
placez-les dans la terre, et ils aideront à faire pousser un arbre.
Le cadre de notre prochaine exploration utilisant les mêmes principes de design
était le système solaire.
Nous avons considéré la possibilité de créer des vêtements de maintien en vie
pour des voyages inter-planétaires.
Pour faire cela, nous avions besoin de contenir les bactéries
et de contrôler leur circulation.
Nous avons mis en place un tableau d'éléments, comme le tableau périodique :
de nouvelles formes de vie créées par ordinateur,
fabriquées additivement
et propagées biologiquement.
J'aime penser à la biologie synthétique comme étant de l'alchimie liquide,
mais au lieu de transformer des métaux précieux,
vous synthétisez de nouvelles fonctionnalités biologiques
dans de très petits canaux.
Cela s'appelle la microfluidique.
Nous avons imprimé nos canaux en 3D afin de contrôler le flux
de ces cultures bactériennes liquides.
Dans notre premier habit, nous avons combiné deux micro-organismes.
Le premier est la cyanobactérie.
Elle vit dans nos océans et dans les bassins d'eau douce.
Et la deuxième, E. Coli, la bactérie qui vit dans les intestins humains.
L'une transforme la lumière en sucre, l'autre consomme ce sucre
et produit des carburants biologiques utiles pour construire l'environnement.
Ces deux micro-organismes n'interagissent jamais dans la nature.
En fait, ils ne se sont jamais rencontrés.
Ils sont là, conçus pour la première fois
pour avoir une relation à l'intérieur d'un vêtement.
Voyez ça comme l'évolution pas par la sélection naturelle,
mais par le design.
Afin de contenir ces relations,
nous avons créé un canal unique qui ressemble au tube digestif
et qui aidera à faire circuler ces bactéries
et à changer leurs fonctions au cours du trajet.
Nous avons ensuite fait grandir ces canaux sur le corps humain,
faisant varier les propriétés de la matière selon la fonction souhaitée.
Quand nous voulions plus de photosynthèse, nous créions des canaux plus transparents.
Ce système digestif portable, quand il est étiré,
mesure 60 mètres.
C'est la moitié d'un terrain de football,
et 10 fois plus long que notre intestin grêle.
Et le voici dévoilé pour la première fois à TED --
nous premier canal liquide,
photosynthétique et portable brillant de vie dans un vêtement.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Mary Shelley a dit : « Nous sommes des créatures indémodables,
mais seulement à moitié finies. »
Et si le design pouvait fournir la deuxième moitié ?
Et si nous pouvions créer des structures qui augmenteraient la matière vivante ?
Et si nous pouvions créer des micro-biomes personnels
qui analyseraient notre peau, répareraient les tissus abimés
et nourriraient notre corps ?
Pensez-y comme étant une forme de biologie modifiée.
Cette collection entière, Wanderers, qui a pris son nom de planètes,
ne tenait, pour moi, pas vraiment de la mode en soi,
mais donnait une opportunité de spéculer sur le futur
de notre race sur notre planète et au-delà,
de combiner une vision scientifique à beaucoup de mystères
et de s'éloigner de l'âge de la machine
pour aller vers un nouvel âge de symbiose entre nos corps,
les micro-organismes qui vivent en nous,
nos produits et mêmes nos bâtiments.
J'appelle cela l'écologie matérielle.
Pour faire cela, nous avons toujours besoin de retourner à la nature.
Vous savez maintenant qu'une imprimante 3D imprime les matériaux par couches.
Ce n'est pas le cas de la nature.
La nature grandit. Elle ajoute de la sophistication.
Le cocon du ver à soie, par exemple,
crée une architecture hautement sophistiquée,
une maison dans laquelle se métamorphoser.
Aucune fabrication additive ne s'approche de ce niveau de sophistication.
Il est atteint en combinant non pas deux matières,
mais deux protéines en différentes concentrations.
L'une agit comme une structure, l'autre est la colle, ou la matrice,
maintenant ces fibres ensemble.
Cela se produit à différentes échelles.
Le ver à soie commence par s'attacher à l'environnement --
cela crée une structure tensostatique --
puis il commence à filer un cocon compressif.
La tension et la compression, les deux forces de la vie,
s'exprimant dans un seul matériau.
Afin de mieux comprendre la complexité du fonctionnement de ce processus,
nous avons collé un petit aimant naturel
sur la tête d'un ver à soie, à la filière.
Nous l'avons mis dans une boite avec des capteurs magnétiques,
cela nous a permis de créer ce nuage de points en 3 dimensions
et de visualiser l'architecture complexe du cocon du ver à soie.
Quand nous avons placé le ver à soie sur une surface plate,
pas à l'intérieur d'une boite,
nous avons réalisé qu'il filait un cocon plat
et qu'il se métamorphoserait sainement.
Nous avons commencé à créer différents environnements et échafaudages.
Nous avons découvert que la forme, la composition,
la structure du cocon étaient directement impactées par l'environnement.
Les vers à soie sont souvent cuits dans leur cocon jusqu'à leur mort,
leur soie est démêlée et utilisée dans l'industrie textile.
Nous avons réalisé que créer ces modèles nous permettait de donner une forme
à la soie brute
sans faire cuire un seul cocon.
(Applaudissements)
Ils se métamorphosent sainement
et sont capables de créer ces choses.
Nous avons redimensionné le processus à l'échelle architecturale.
Un robot filait le modèle en soie,
et nous le placions sur notre site.
Nous savions que les vers à soie migraient vers des zones plus sombres et froides,
nous avons donc utilisé le chemin du soleil
pour mettre à jour la distribution
de la lumière et de la chaleur sur notre structure.
Nous avons ensuite créé des trous, ou ouvertures,
qui concentreraient les rayons de lumière et de chaleur,
distribuant ces vers à soie sur la structure.
Nous étions prêts à recevoir les chenilles.
Nous avons commandé 6 500 vers à soie à une magnanerie en ligne.
Après 4 semaines d'alimentation, ils étaient prêts à filer.
Nous les avons prudemment placés sur le bord le plus élevé de l'échafaudage,
et, en filant, ils se nymphosent, s'accouplent, pondent des œufs,
et la vie recommence -- comme nous mais en beaucoup plus court.
Bucky Fuller a dit que la tension était la grande intégrité,
et il avait raison.
Alors qu'ils filent de la soie biologique sur de la soie filée par un robot,
ils donnent son intégrité à ce pavillon entier.
En 2 ou 3 semaines,
6 500 vers à soie filent 6 500 kilomètres.
Avec une symétrie étrange, c'est également la longueur de la Route de la Soie.
Les papillons, une fois éclos, produisent 1,5 millions d’œufs.
Cela pourrait être utilisé pour 250 autres pavillons.
Donc les voici, les deux visions du monde.
L'une file de la soie avec un bras robotisé,
l'autre comble les trous.
Si la frontière finale du design est d'amener la vie dans les produits
et les bâtiments qui nous entourent,
de créer une écologie à deux matières,
alors les designers doivent unir ces deux visions du monde.
Ce qui, bien sûr, nous ramène au commencement.
A un nouvel âge de design, un nouvel âge de création,
qui nous amène d'un design inspiré par la nature
à une nature inspirée par le design,
et qui nous demande pour la première fois
d'agir comme mère nature.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup. Merci.